movies are dreams
[Music]
that you never forget
sammy
[Music]
the lights change how everything looks
it's hard to find our house
marsh is the dark house with no lights
in this family it's the scientists
versus the artists
[Music]
sammy's on my team takes after me
[Music]
what kind of movie we're gonna make
you dismiss what he does it's playful or
imaginative
you could afford to be a little
encouraging
she should have been a concert piano
player
what she got in her heart is what you
got
you can't just love something you also
have to take care of it it's more
important than your hobby
can you stop calling it a hobby
mom got a monkey
why'd you get a monkey because i needed
a laugh
and you always have to be the center of
attention stop shouting at her that has
been nothing but disrespect from you i'm
your mother
family art
it'll tear you into
you stop making movies it'll break your
mother's heart
i don't know what to do anymore
you do what your heart says you have to
what was your favorite part
[Music]
you